mikrochips werden heute schon in zahlreichen bereichen des lebens eingesetzt in die haut eingepflanzt
ersetzt der schlüssel und kreditkarten außerdem werden haustiere mit chips ausgestattet und lieferungen werden verfolgt mittlerweile
Also alles andere als science fiction schon mehr als
10.000 reale personen haben die schätzungen zufolge bereits so einen vernetzten chip in ihrem körper was können solche
technologisch aufgerüsteten körper bereits und wohin führt das alles ich sage nur
technologische singularität danke für den dem vorschlag über whatsapp und herzlich willkommen bei klicks und science fiction
Und wir euch hier über whatsapp und andere messenger verknüpft das erfahrt ihr am ende des videos wir reden hier ja immer öfter mal wieder
über die zahlreichen möglichkeiten den menschlichen körper technologisch aufzurüsten
forschungsteams aus ärzten ingenieuren und anderen wissenschaftlern
haben es schon seit längerer zeit möglich gemacht chips zu implantieren mit denen sich beispielsweise
Türen öffnen lassen diejenigen die die chips tragen nennen sich bio hackers iboxx oder gründer und bei manchen von ihnen verrät eine rot leuchtende led
dass sie solch einen chip unter ihrer haut tragen aber es sind nicht wenige menschen die sich zum teil selbst als versuchskaninchen für
Eine revolutionäre technologie sehen sie 2015 beispielsweise können sich auch die 2000 angestellten eines schwedischen
startup zentrums mit einem chip so groß wie ein reiskorn
Ausstatten lassen damit sparen sie sich schlüssel und portemonnaie der chip
öffnet ihnen die türen und auch das mittagessen in der kantine wird darüber abgerechnet oder
der snack aus dem automaten der lässt sich damit ganz einfach bezahlen außerdem lassen sich damit auch die drucker im büro bedienen
Und das interesse ist groß und so gibt es regelmäßige partys bei denen sich die mitarbeiter und mitarbeiterinnen
den chip einsetzen lassen diese implantate basieren auf der near field communication technologie kurz nfc
Ein lesegerät das sich in der nähe befindet aktiviert sie und liest informationen aus die hier verwendeten chips
verhalten sich passiv das heißt sie speichern die daten können aber selbst keine informationen lesen oder sie von sich aus
abgeben, biologische medizinisch gesehen sind sich die meisten experten
experten einig dass die implantate als unbedenklich gelten
diskussionswürdig ist dagegen wieder mal das thema überwachung und datenschutz denn bezogen auf das büro beispiel aus schweden wäre es natürlich ein leichtes
für das unternehmen die mitarbeiter zu überwachen wann und wo sind sie unterwegs
Was ist eher so wie lange macht sie pause und im gegensatz zu den daten die
smartphones um beispielsweise bankkarten sammeln werden über die mikrochips solche informationen permanent
gesammelt man kann sie wieder ausschalten noch geht das akku irgendwann
Knie und einmal unter die haut gepflanzten lassen sie sich natürlich nicht so schnell mal eben zur seite legen solche daten zur
pause n'dour und infos zu messen sind nicht die einzige infos die man aus einem körper mit eingepflanzten chip erhalten könnte die
ausgereifte die chips umso größer das ethische dilemma ob gegebenenfalls auch informationen übermittelt werden
Die eigentlich alles andere als öffentlich sind beispielsweise wo man sich wann aufhält mit wem man sich trifft dem partner oder die partnerin
betrübt und so weiter bislang ist dies noch nicht so einfach möglich dafür müsste erst einmal eine körper freundliche energieversorgung solche aufwendiger chips
entwickelt werden dann könnten sich auf diesen chips die daten ganz am mikrocomputer unterbringen lassen
Leistungsfähiger prozessoren würden dann beispielsweise auch das online banking möglich machen oder aber die identifikation der eigenen person so dass
staaten die chips als
identitätsfeststellung der einwohner nutzen können weil diese noch zukunftsmusik ist fehlen bislang
auch einheitliche sicherheitsstandards dazu spätestens dann wenn man als bürger dazu angehalten bzw in gewisser art und weise
gezwungen wird sich chips implantieren zu lassen müsste es bestimmte sicherheitsgarantien geben denn
stellt euch mal vor getippte menschen als eine art usb stick auf zwei beiden der daten austauschen kopieren und übertragen kann
doch den eigenen körper kann man beim besuch oder beim termin mit dem bankberater nicht einfach zu hause lassen wie eben einen usb stick und
So müssten zugriffsrechte geklärt werden so dass der arzt oder die ärztin nicht an den kontostand der patienten und patientinnen kommt und die
bankberater eben nur an diesen nicht aber an die gesundheitsdaten
dass kunden und die fragen gehen noch weiter möchte
ich überhaupt dass mein arzt wenn man eine ärztin jederzeit über alle meine lebensgewohnheiten bescheid was
dass eltern immer wissen wo ihre kinder gerade sind und was weiß dann mein chef oder eine chefin alles über mich
was eigentlich in den bereich privatleben gehört nicht allzu weit entfernt ist auch das szenario dass es gelingt künstliche
intelligenz mit auf die chips zu bringen das würde noch ganz andere möglichkeiten eröffnen die mikrochips könnten als eine art frühwarnsystem
dienen dass aufgrund der körpertemperatur
Dem puls oder der müdigkeit auf eine gefahrenquelle hinweis hier die apple watch ist ja so ein schritt in diese richtung man kann sie ablegen
und nicht nur bei einem selbst sondern auch bei den menschen in unserer umgebung nicht nur das stellt euch vor ich steigt ins auto doch
weigert sich loszufahren schließlich hat das erkannt das ist ja gerade so unruhig und wüten seit dass das autofahren zu gefährlich wäre
klingt zwar noch nach science fiction ist aber tatsächlich in teilen schon real in großbritannien beispielsweise zeigen fitness am ende an ob beamte
unter besonders hohem stress stehen und apropos gesundheit wie sieht es aus mit viren die die mikrochips in menschlichen körpern
verseuchen durch viren angriffe von hackern
beispielsweise klar ist jedenfalls dass jede technische entwicklung in diesem bereich auch von
cyberkriminellen genau beobachtet wird und die persönlicher und vertraulicher die daten sind desto lukrativer
Können diese auch für kriminelle seien das
maximale szenario
werden dann sogar chips die zb vernetzt mit dem herzschrittmacher und anderen devices im körper und steuern oder sogar mit dem gehirn verknüpft
sind und wieso zugriff auf künstliche intelligenz hätten und und und und und aber das wäre ja schon die technologische singularität
es ist der nächste große schritt zu auf einen spektakulären moment tritt diese vorher gesagt der
technologische singularität ein wird die technik den menschen überholen und sich selbst ständig neu erfinden dann ist die entwicklung der menschheit nicht mehr
vorhersagbar und es könnten riesige
technologische fortschritte in kürzester zeit erreicht werden allerdings mit solchen mikrochips im körper könnten dann auch menschen gehackt werden
eine ganz andere form von viren keine rosige perspektiven
wenn ihr zu den ersten gehören wollte die neues dazu erfahren dann endet meine telefonnummer hier bei whatsapp wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr euch auch
mit mir über telegramm instagram oder den facebook messenger verknüpften dann erfahrt ihr von mir
Vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert können dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von krieg zu
machen wir zum beispiel wie dieses thema hier themen vorschlagen einfach hier draufklicken und zerbröseln habe ich ein kleines goodie für euch dort im begrüßungstext
versteckt und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
genau noch vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken der größte kanten computer der welt von google vorgestellt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran